[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous et missions
spéciales rentrée parlementaire dans
savouregarde ce soir avec quatre jeunes
députés quatre visages nouveaux et
emblématiques de la nouvelle donne
politique à l'Assemblée avec eux on va
revenir sur cette journée électrique au
Palais Bourbon les retrouvailles ont été
explosives la session démarre sur les
chapeaux de roue assurance chômage
budget retraite le tout sous la double
menace de la censure et de la
dissolution grand débat spécial dans un
instant avec nos invités sur ce plateau
notre grand témoin ce soir revient du
Crès il faisait partie de la délégation
à Kiev conduite par Yaël Braun pivel la
présidente de l'Assemblée qui est un
grand intellectuelle grand Européen
aussi il préside la commission des
affaires étrangères ici à l'Assemblée
Jean-Louis bourlange nous accorde un
grand entretien ce soir voilà pour le
programme sévère première session
ordinaire 16e législature c'est parti
[Musique]
l'Assemblée nationale redevient donc le
centre du jeu politique bonsoir à tous
en témoigne la séance de questions au
gouvernement pour le moins tendu on va y
revenir dans le détail une session
parlementaire qui s'annonce donc
physique car sans majorité absolue tout
devient possible 49-3 motions de censure
dissolution voici comment les députés la
voix cette rentrée
désorganiser chaud bouillant offensive
opposition ferme c'est un peu le bordel
voilà le ton est donné et ça n'a pas
manqué on va le voir dans l'hémicycle
bonsoir mode région et merci d'être là
député renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine
porte-parole du groupe majoritaire à
l'assemblée bonsoir clémence guettet et
bienvenue sur ce plateau député la
France insoumise du Val-de-Marne et
vice-président du groupe lfi-up à
l'Assemblée nationale bonsoir Thomas
ménager ravi de vous accueillir députés
rassemblement national du Loiret Julien
dive député les républicains de l'Aisne
va nous rejoindre dans un tout petit
instant alors pour vous trois c'est
votre premier mandat vous allez nous
dire exactement comment vous l'envisagez
dans ce contexte inédit mais d'abord
l'oeil de Blacko si j'ai bien compris
les questions gouvernement c'était la
première session on y va voilà tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir si j'ai bien compris on s'attendait
à ce que cette entreprise parlementaire
soit particulièrement animée d'ailleurs
les députés eux-mêmes en témoigne on les
a interrogé quelques-uns avant le début
de la séance d'aujourd'hui et vous voyez
qu'on a entendu de la majorité
s'attendait d'autant plus à être attaqué
que ceux de l'opposition promettait
d'être extrêmement offensif donc le
décor était planté d'emblée quoi
pourtant ça a commencé dans une belle
unanimité mais oui mais quelle surprise
mais il faut dire que c'est quand même
une bonne idée un joli Cook jouer Yann
Brown Pivet la présidente de l'Assemblée
parce que pour prouver que l'assemblée
n'est pas que le lieu des claquements de
pupitre des invectives des discussions
de sourds elle s'était mise d'accord
avec les présidents de groupe pour
rendre un image unanime aux Iraniens qui
protestent en ce moment et aux
iraniennes voilà qui protestent en ce
moment contre la dictature religieuse
dans leur pays alors regardez son
initiative a vraiment apprécié parce que
tout le monde applaudit on voyait au
début même à l'extrême gauche les gens
de la nuit pêche qui applaudissaient
jusqu'à droite
l'extrême gauche dans notre pays il y a
des partis politiques c'est le NPA c'est
du tout ouvrière c'est pas nous d'accord
moi je disais justement l'extrême gauche
dans l'hémicycle c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
personne plus à gauche que vous en ai
mis cycle mais en dehors
effectivement elle a pas été dur elle
était de courte durée parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on attendait c'est
pas vraiment l'opposition qui a porté
les premiers coups mais plutôt la
majorité donc l'attaque elle est venue
dans Hors berger qui est la présidente
du groupe Renaissance donc elle a
commencé par lire le témoignage de
femmes qui étaient victimes de violence
conjugales donc ce témoignage disait ça
a commencé par une petite gifle puis on
est passé au coup de poing mais rien que
le moment où elle a dit le mot gifle on
a senti qu'il y avait une petite
crispation sur le banc de l'équipe parce
que forcément ça faisait penser à la
polémique qui a eu autour de Damien
Cattin ces derniers temps mais a a été
encore plus précise elle a fini par
faire de reproches à peine voilée sur la
manière dont le groupe et les filles a
pris la défense d'Adrien catenain sont
l'écoute
depuis plusieurs semaines
ont reçu de celui qui reconnaît des
faits de violence conjugales depuis
plusieurs semaines on entend ce qui
parle de leur affection pour un homme
qui frappe sa femme depuis plusieurs
semaines on fait fier des règles
élémentaires de l'État de droit on jette
le discrédit sur les femmes et les
hommes policiers et gendarmes qui au
périls de leur vie interviennent après
des signalements de violences conjugales
alors quel a été la réaction du groupe
LFI ils auraient bien voulu réagir ils
étaient un peu piégés parce qu'en
réalité c'est une question gouvernement
donc Aurore berger s'adresse poser sa
question à la première ministre et donc
le départ prévu de tendre le micro aux
insoumis pour qu'ils puissent répondre
immédiatement donc regardez ça donne
cette image ou d'un côté la majorité se
lève pour applaudir Aurore berger
pendant des insoumis eux puisque on
n'est pas prévu le règlement de prévoit
pas de leur donner la parole dans ces
circonstances qu'on se sont réduits à
râler sur leur rang alors pas tout à
fait réduit au silence non plus puisque
Daniel le Bono elle a continué de
manifester son indignation à tel point
que elle criait si fort que
la présidente l'a sanctionné on écoute
[Musique]
vous continuez à invectiver l'assemblée
et à activer la présidence si c'est ce
que vous faites
quand on sait que le ministre Darmanin
qui a quand même été mis en cause pour
avoir échangé des faveurs sexuelles
contre des relations sexuelles contre un
logement quand on sait que Monsieur
Damien bad reste sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale sans qu'il n'y ait
aucune mesure prise alors que ce dont il
est question ce sont les faits de viol
répété et avec des témoignages et on est
là à avoir des leçons d'un groupe
politique si je devais avoir un seul
motéminable et ça nous met très en
colère donc il y a pourtant beaucoup de
sujets qui ont été abordés pendant ces
questions gouvernement notamment sur
l'énergie marine Le Pen a parlé du fioul
Olivier Marley que ça parlait la
situation de certaines entreprises mais
c'est vrai que cette attaque de Robert
Berger a plus dominé les débats donc
d'un côté on entend le gouvernement qui
plaide le compromis la discussion
constructive bon après une attaque
pareil on sent que ça ne se fera pas
cette discussion constructive pas avec
les filles pour l'instant mais je ne
suis pas sûr que les filles avaient
prévu d'avoir des vraiment des compromis
bâti avec le gouvernement on va essayer
de voir plus clair maintenant merci
beaucoup beaucoup merci Stéphane pour
votre biais on va pas parler que de ce
qui s'est passé au début de question au
gouvernement c'est le 1er mai quand même
rien n'est fait au hasard bonne raison
vous savez très bien que vous êtes très
regardé d'autant plus qu'il y a une
attente des Français avec cette nouvelle
donne politique vous en parlez entre
vous au sein du groupe pour savoir
comment vous allez pour la première
séance de questions au Gouvernement
incarner la voix de la majorité monsieur
on en parle et on interprète les
ministres sur des questions qui nous
tiennent à cœur qui tiennent à cœur aux
Français et Aurore Berger a eu raison de
le faire les violences conjugales
premier terrain d'affrontement alors on
parle il y a 99 femmes qui ont été tuées
par leur conjoint en leur ex-conjoint
depuis le début de l'année c'est
extrêmement important on a tous été
choqué de l'attitude d'une partie de la
France insoumise je vous le dis à
l'égard d'Adrien cadenas c'est la façon
dont s'exprimer notamment Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il s'agit pas de rendre
justice sur les plateaux de télé ou sur
les réseaux sociaux mais d'accorder un
minimum de crédit à la parole des femmes
quant à la prise de parole de kimoine
j'en viens
mais c'est intéressant je vous donne la
parole dans un instant je vous ai pas
interdire vous soyez choqué concernant
ministre de l'Intérieur il y a eu quatre
décisions de justice qui ont été rendues
de non-lieu deux ordonnances de non-lieu
et deux annulations de classements
sensibles
et un homme qui a bénéficié monsieur
Peyrat 4 de 4 excusez-moi de 4 décisions
intéressantes et entre un autre qui
reconnaît lui-même avoir
fait subir des violences conjugales à sa
femme je pense qu'il y a une petite
différence la réponse est vrai que bon
la majorité vous pouvez pas de cadeaux
d'entrée de jeu mais vous lui avez pas
fait non plus sur tous les cas que vous
venez de citer c'est pas une question de
faire des cadeaux ou pas en fait que que
Madame berger décide de se saisir de la
question des violences conjugales
honnêtement j'ai aucun problème contre
ça c'est c'est dans notre programme nous
sommes féministes c'est une question qui
est importante les violences sont
structurelles dans la société on sait
que ça a lieu partout et on en a
beaucoup parlé ces deux dernières
semaines donc on sait qu'on n'est pas à
l'abri de ça c'est pas ça le problème le
problème c'est le sa question qui en
fait est pas une question sur les
violences conjugales qui est une
question de polémique politique
nous est directement
adressée alors même qu'on ne peut pas y
répondre donc c'est vraiment une façon
étonnante de commencer cette cette
session et puis c'est surtout le deux
poids de mesure en fait que les membres
de la majorité soient choqués par nos
expressions notre traitement des
violences sexistes et sexuelles c'est
une chose mais nous nous disons les
violences sont inacceptables et quand il
y a des cas des affaires dans nos rangs
et ben on essaye d'y répondre du mieux
qu'on peut reconnaître que ce soit
perfectible
les Français de voir le site de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon y compris dans votre famille
sans doute et y compris ces perfectible
et il faudra faire mieux sur ce sujet ça
c'est sûr par contre moi je veux qu'on
s'intéresse à Monsieur Abad qui revient
alors qu'il est accusé de trois viols en
ayant drogué des femmes et que là il y a
pas encore eu de décision de justice à
ce que je sa
démissionne de son mandat député en fait
je suis pas là pour demander quelque
chose ce que je veux dire c'est
appliquons à tout le monde les mêmes
traitements je crois que Madame Berger a
été sur ce coup-là hypocrite et que
c'était un coup politique qui était
assez petit voilà un coup politiqueien
ou un vrai sujet sur lequel la majorité
a eu raison de d'aller d'entrée de jeu
je rappelle que le RN est assez absente
ces sujets on a l'impression que vous
préférez regarder les balles passées non
pas du tout moi j'ai rebondir ce que
deux poids de mesure on a le sentiment
depuis des mois en fait que la France
insoumise la nuit pèse était en deux
poids de mesure c'est à dire que on
donnait des leçons sur la présomption en
oubliant totalement la présomption
d'innocence en salissant un certain
nombre de personnes si si vous oubliez
le
de la même manière on prend des
décisions politiques internes qui n'ont
rien réglé en donnant des leçons aux
autres qui n'en n'avaient pas nous on a
toujours une règle la justice rien que
la justice
interne comme les vôtres qui entre
guillemets et tout depuis des décisions
monsieur
cellule d'écoute interne au
rassemblements nationales c'est vrai que
les voies des femmes ne sont pas très
nombreuses mais on a aussi on a un
conseil de discipline on a aussi nous on
pense qu'on pense qu'elle a justice
madame guetter mais ça a servi à quoi
regardez le nombre de cas chez vous
pensez qu'il y a pas besoin d'écouter
les femmes
de violence former les magistrats qu'on
doit apporter des moyens humains
matériels supplémentaires aux forces de
l'ordre pour traiter la même chose
laissez-moi finir nous on considère
qu'elle a justice rien que la justice il
doit pas y avoir une justice privée une
justice parallèle forcément vous avez
voulu créer des justiciers qui n'ont pas
marché
tout le monde respecte la présence la
même manière quand c'est Monsieur Abad
je n'ai pas commandé quand c'était
monsieur 4 nain je n'ai pas commenté je
laisse la justice faire son travail et
c'est ça notre ligne et on nous a manque
une ligne sur ce bonsoir Julien dive
bonsoir je disais on avait trois
nouveaux visages donc c'est le premier
mandat non mais c'est votre deuxième
mandat je rappelle que vous êtes député
les républicains de laine qu'est-ce qui
dit ce bras de fer d'entrée de jeu comme
ça dans l'hémicycle vous qui avez un peu
plus d'expérience est-ce que ça augure
de de séance électrique 37 ans
mais c'est un grand classique en fait
les rentrés sont classiques et rentrer
dans les dans l'hémicycle avec les
questions gouvernement qui sont toujours
houleuses j'ai envie de dire c'est
presque une tradition mais c'est normal
on sort soit de période de campagne soit
de période estivales ou on est chauffé à
blanc aussi sur le retour des
circonscriptions ou les Français nous
interroge au quotidien lorsqu'on est sur
le terrain et évident quand on se
retrouve dans l'hémicycle ben ça ça
s'exprime ça s'exprime soit sur un texte
lorsqu'il y a un débat soit lors des
questions gouvernement c'est lors des
questions
c'est à la hauteur on sent qu'il y a un
moment Assemblée nationale espérons
qu'il dure parce que cette nouvelle
donne vraiment voilà créer une véritable
curiosité une attention vous vous devez
être exemplaire aussi être exemplaire ça
n'empêche pas de débattre ça n'empêche
pas de parfois hausser le ton il y a des
colères qui sont saines après ce qui
compte c'est ne pas faire le bordel
comme on dit c'est pas seulement
expression c'est un terme un peu
vulgaire mais c'est pourtant ce que
traduise beaucoup de Français c'est de
ne pas faire le bazar dans l'hémicycle
il y a le débat il y a les colères les
colères saines il y a les polémiques ça
fait partie du jeu politique maintenant
ce qui ce qu'il ce qu'il compte c'est de
pouvoir se tenir et je pense que
là-dessus même si on a tous des
désaccords on essaie au mieux de s'y
préparer les accords les désaccords on
va essayer de voir où sont les compromis
possibles sur les textes et vous avez du
pain sur la planche en cette rentrée
mais d'abord on a parlé d'Adrien catenin
grand absent de l'hémicycle aujourd'hui
pour clore cette séquence elle demande
un GABA vous êtes salle des quatre
colonnes il y a en revanche un député
qui a fait son grand retour c'est c'est
Julien Bayou Elsa
celui qui était qu'au président du
groupe ELV et qui n'est plus que député
à bien organisé sa défense oui
exactement on sent bien que parmi les
députés écologistes on essaye de tourner
un petit peu la page puisque quand on
leur pose des questions tous aimerait
bien revenir à des questions de fond des
questions de programme mais et bien nous
les journalistes on les ramène souvent
évidemment à cette présence de Julien
Bayou donc ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'effectivement il était présent
en réunion de groupe ce matin avec
Sandrine Rousseau après cette réunion de
groupe il y a la présidente du groupe
maintenant celle qui était qu'au
présidente avant la démission de Julien
Bayou Cyrielle châtelain qui a fait une
conférence de presse alors elle a
répondu aux questions sans tabou écouter
ce que dit Cyrielle châtelain elle était
en conférence de presse autour de 14
heures
studieuse
non mais voilà apaisé fait partie du
groupe
aujourd'hui on a 23 membres dans notre
groupe ils ont toutes leurs places enfin
il n'y a pas de débat
alors Julien Bayou il était présent dans
l'hémicycle il n'a pas parlé aux médias
puisqu'il a réservé sa parole à une
émission d'une chaîne concurrente
effectivement on aimerait bien tourner
peut-être la page mais on sent bien
effectivement et bien que les
journalistes nous on reste encore un
petit peu sur ce sujet notamment sur les
relations entre députés puisque au sein
de ce groupe écologiste il y a
maintenant franchement une un
affrontement entre Julien Bayou et
Sandrine Rousseau on parlera évidemment
du fond avec les députés écologistes
mais le cas Julien Bayou ne semble pas
complètement définitivement réglés merci
Elsa on vous retrouve un peu plus tard
avec un député MoDem à votre à votre
micro alors le fond on y vient le
programme je le disais il est de taille
la réforme de l'assurance chômage c'est
le premier texte on débat depuis cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle alors il va
sans doute cliver à gauche ensuite il y
aura le projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables qui te livrera à droite et
au milieu il y a le budget pour 2023 et
le budget de la Sécurité sociale le
gouvernement la quasiment déjà dit 49-3
sur les textes budgétaires c'est une
carte maîtresse le 49.3 dans le jeu du
gouvernement mais qui n'est pas sans
risque Clément Pergaud
[Musique]
le scénario de la bataille parlementaire
qui s'annonce semble écrit d'avance
faute de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
le gouvernement n'a pas les cartes en
main pour faire voter le prochain budget
pour plier la partie il devrait donc
dégainer son joker
le fameux 49,3
ce chiffre mythique désigne l'alinéa 3
de l'article 49 de la Constitution
lequel précise le Premier ministre peut
engager la responsabilité du
Gouvernement devant l'Assemblée
nationale sur le vote d'un projet de loi
de finance ou de financement de la
sécurité sociale
mais attention depuis 2008 l'usage de la
carte 49.3 est limitée elle ne peut être
utilisée que pour le budget plus un
projet de loi par session parlementaire
le 49-3 permet donc d'adopter un texte
sans passer par un vote une méthode
impopulaire car souvent jugée brutal
voire anti-démocratique mais le
gouvernement n'a pas vraiment le choix
pour des raisons de principe de symboles
politiques les oppositions d'envisage
pas de voter le budget ça laisse peu de
suspense sur l'issue puisque nous avons
une majorité relative dans les rangs de
la majorité le mot d'ordre est passé il
faut dédramatiser l'usage du 49-3 le
49-3 n'est pas un gros mot c'est un
article de la Constitution qui permet
d'adopter un texte en cas d'absence de
majorité absolue ou d'obstruction
parlementaire l'utilisation d'une règle
de droit n'est pas une violation du
droit mais l'usage du 49-3 permet aussi
à l'opposition de déposer une motion de
censure contre le gouvernement certains
adversaires politiques d'Emmanuel Macron
ne se prive pas de le rappeler il faut
qu'Emmanuel Macron comprenne que les
résultats des élections législatives lui
ont donné une majorité relative si je
souhaite passer en force qui se méfie
parce qu'en règle générale quand il y a
un 49 3 il peut aussi y avoir une motion
de censure et ne nous interdisons pas de
la voter si le 49-3 est utilisé sur le
budget il semble peu probable qu'une
éventuelle motion de censure puisse
rassembler plus de la moitié des votes
dans l'émission mais la majorité avance
un peu dans l'inconnu la dernière fois
que le 49-3 a été dégainé pour un budget
c'était en 1992 le Premier ministre
était alors Pierre Bérégovoy
mode Braison vous allez les dégainer le
49-3 sur le budget
possible sur le budget ça dépend de
l'opposition ça dépend de leur
comportement dans l'hémicycle dans
quelle mesure on est sur une vraie
volonté de dialogue sur une vraie
volonté de débat ou est-ce que au
contraireio on est dans une logique
d'obstruction on verra ça dans quelques
jours vous imaginez quand même que une
dernière les Français vous regardent
c'est le premier grand texte 49-3 pas de
vote vous pensez qu'ils vont comprendre
sur la question du budget on verra
quelles sont les positionnements des uns
et des autres c'est un texte qui est
éminemment politique et donc quand on
est dans l'opposition on peut par
principe parfois voter contre le budget
si effectivement
avec le contenu à chaque fois qu'on
parle vous nous interrompez on va pas
s'en sortir dans ce débat donc on vous
laisse parler vous nous laissez pas
c'est un débat
présenter ce budget ensuite son accord
seront pas d'accord les votes se font
mais effectivement chacun comprend qu'il
y a besoin d'un budget pour la France et
puis il va falloir un moment qu'on
arrive à aller sur le fond expliquer ce
qu'il y a dedans par exemple le bouclier
de tarifaire sur l'énergie comment
est-ce qu'on préserve les Français des
Hauss j'ai pris du gaz et oser pris
l'électricité qu'à augmenter de plus de
100% en 1er janvier prochain si on
l'avait pas incluse dans ce budget c'est
quelque chose d'important donc
concentre-nous sur le fond et puis après
sur la teneur des débats encore une fois
nous on a tendu la main à l'opposition
il y a les dialogues de Bercy ils sont
allés alors les oppositions je vous
propose Julien 10 ça m'intéresse parce
que on dit toujours voter le budget
c'est faire partie de la majorité les
républicains vont forcément tous voter
contre je pense
67 62 contre s'abstenir je sais pas on
verra dans le détail et la limite c'est
pas le plus important la question c'est
de savoir ce qu'il y a dans ce budget et
aujourd'hui ce budget c'est encore une
fois emprunté les milliards sur les
marchés à des taux d'intérêt importants
avec 17 milliards de dettes rien
d'intérêt pardon de taux d'intérêt à
rembourser s'il y a une crise des dettes
souveraines c'est un cataclysme pour la
France donc c'est obligé de prévoit pas
une prothèse ni la France ni les
Français donc aujourd'hui ce budget
n'est pas sincère et il n'est pas
question de voter en l'état s'empêchera
pas qu'on défendra des amendements qu'on
défendra des positions après le sujet
c'est pas tant que le texte soit adopté
ou pas que le budget soit adopté ou pas
le sujet c'est pas tant qu'il y ait 49
pro ou pas puisque de toute façon on
sait depuis le départ depuis le mois de
juin qu'il n'y a pas de majorité absolue
à l'Assemblée nationale on sait depuis
le départ depuis le mois de juin que les
budgets risquent de passer par le 49-3
c'est plutôt ce qui en découle ce qui
est intéressant à regarder c'est ce qui
découlera de ce 49-3 est-ce qu'il y aura
l'adoption d'une motion ou pas et ce
qu'il y aura une réaction ou pas du
présent République c'est ça qui
intéresse on se souvient tous des mots
issus du dîner à l'Élysée de d'Emmanuel
Macron s'il y a une motion de censure
c'est le gouvernement est renversé tout
le monde repart en campagne comme ça
c'est clair le président n'a pas peur de
la dissolution Clémence guetter pour
vous 49-3 entraîne systématiquement des
produits de motion de censure au sein
des défis déjà la première chose c'est
que nous non plus on a pas peur d'une
dissolution on sait faire campagne on
l'a fait il y a moins d'un an si jamais
le président use de ce de ce pouvoir
monarchique là en plus de tous ceux dont
il a utilisé jusqu'ici il le fera et il
nous repartirons en campagne je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il le fasse pour des raisons
d'intérêt est-ce que est-ce que les
macronistes gagneront beaucoup de
circonscriptions dans un tel Paris je
n'en suis pas sûr donc nous verrons
toujours est-il que il y a une petite
ambiance de de chantage permanent et de
tension de notre système démocratique
quand même on s'est rentrée parce que en
effet ben si les oppositions s'opposent
à un texte comme le budget ça n'est non
pas pour une position de principe non
pas une question symbolique comme le
disait votre le sujet et la déclaration
de Monsieur Attal mais c'est bien parce
que le contenu de ce budget et je
rejoins mon collègue le contenu de ce
budget
nous ne nous va pas
de production à eux par exemple ou le
fait qu'on ne finance toujours pas assez
les services publics qui sont en train
de s'effondrer c'est ça le réel problème
donc en effet si en plus de ça on nous
dit bon bah 49-3 on vous laisse un petit
peu discuter quelques semaines vous
serez content puis 49-3 évidemment nous
nous déposerons une notion de censure
petite question et je vous donne la
parole Thomas ménager si c'est le RN qui
dépose la motion censure impossible que
les LFI ne la votent impossible ou vous
pouvez mêler vos voix donc donc c'est ça
ma réponse c'est à dire que le
rassemblement national je ne sais pas
s'ils le front sans doute qu'ils le font
en tout cas nous nous le ferons et nous
aurons le groupe le plus nombreux à le
faire Thomas ménager on a déjà annoncé
qu'on voit très toute notion de censure
ça déposer dès lors qu'on est d'accord
sur la notion de censure dès lors qu'on
veut déposer qu'on dépose la même motion
de censure même si c'est pas totalement
voilà c'est pas parce qu'il pleut
aujourd'hui que je vais dire qu'il fait
beau parce que je veux absolument me
montrer des différences et je trouve ça
dommage que vous ayez cette position
c'est clair mais peu importe nous euh de
dire donc voterez pas la motion de
censure parce que j'ai dit que la nôtre
c'est à déposer avant la vôtre donc
c'est plutôt à vous que la question va
se poser en fait
dans une nouvelle donne politique et on
est déjà en train d'anticiper d'émotion
de censure déposer d'abord par elle-même
c'est logique à peine les débats
commencés déjà mis un flingue sur la
table excusez-moi de voilà bien entendu
moi je suis gaulliste la 49-3 ça fait
partie de la
constitutions
sur le 49-3 et sur la motion de censure
parce que vous avez peur d'une chose si
vous êtes parmi les derniers des
Mohicans
mais alors on verra si vous votez la
motion censure parce que vous allez être
pas émotion parce que j'écoute votre
discours qui veut dire le but c'est de
faire tomber le gouvernement non mais
moi mon but dans la vie c'est pas de
faire tomber le gouvernement mon but
dans la vie c'est que les Français
soient protégés mon but dans la vie
c'est que mon pays avance mon but dans
la vie c'est que mais c'est notre rôle
de parlementaire justement de faire en
sorte que les Français soient protégés
sur les textes donc 49 et aujourd'hui
la question c'est de faire avancer sur
d'autres sujets maintenant la question
de Monceau sur chacun votera en Amérique
cautions nous nous sommes par principe
responsable et par en termes de
responsabilité il est hors de question
d'aller rajouter du bazar dans le bazar
sauf si vous considez
d'avoir la position des républicains
par contre ce que je dis si on doit y
aller on ira par contre voter une
émotion c'est nette dans nos cadeaux
on le voit bien sur ce plateau elle est
déjà très forte elle peut monter encore
d'un cran dans les semaines qui viennent
est-ce que vous vous dites on va y
arriver on peut garder une forme de
sérénité quand on a déjà agité la
censure la dissolution on entend des
mots très forts chantages flingue sur la
table qu'est-ce que vous répondez je
réponds qu'il y a pas besoin de monter
dans les tours comme ça d'abord on a
montré en juillet qu'on était capable de
voter des textes de trouver des
majorités de projets des majorités
d'objectifs pour le pouvoir d'achat et
il y a des projets qui arrivent sur
l'assurance chômage aujourd'hui vous
discutez pas avec un restaurateur ou un
hôtelier sans qu'il vous disent le mal
qu'il a recruté donc c'est pour ça qu'on
le fait
la question des énergies renouvelables
de l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables c'est dans la loi enfin
c'est dans la programmation on va parler
président de la République de façon
globale sur l'écologie ce qu'on veut
faire sur les retraites ça répond aussi
à un objectif qui est de pérenniser le
système de faire en sorte de produire
davantage de richesses pour rémunérer
davantage des enseignants pour recruter
davantage de policiers pour remontrer le
système de santé
au-delà des questions de 49-3 de motions
de censure et de brouilles qu'on peut
entendre dans l'hémicycle doit y avoir
il faut mettre un peu de fond dans les
débats parce que on est tous d'accord
pour dire qu'on espère que l'Assemblée
nationale va continuer à intéresser les
français si on en a si on reste à ce
niveau là je crains que ça ne dure pas
très longtemps alors partons du premier
texte et puis on parlera d'écologie
après un cycle des retraites mais c'est
l'assurance chômage est-ce que Elisabeth
borne a raison de compter sur les voies
des républicains on va se le dire
franchement sans leur voix ça ne passe
pas mais en même temps si je me souviens
bien vous l'avez porté dans la Valérie
Pécresse vous vous les courtisez vous
les appelez comment ça se passe c'est
une partie effectivement ils l'ont porté
pendant la campagne mais c'est pas
uniquement une histoire de programme
présidentiel c'est que s'il y a des
choses qui nous différencie parmi ce qui
peut nous rassembler il y a l'intérêt
qu'on porte au travail il y a une
certaine une certaine vision du pays
conscience que aujourd'hui il y a un
certain nombre de secteurs qui
n'arrivent pas à recruter et donc il
faut être capable de répondre à ça au
regard de la conjoncture que celle
d'aujourd'hui
on arrive si on arrive à s'accorder sur
ces valeurs là sur cet objectif là
ensuite charge à nous d'abord de
continuer à attendre la main d'écouter
les amendements les propositions qui
seront celles des républicains d'arriver
à converger sur un certain nombre
d'objectifs ensuite le vote qui sera
celui des LR évidemment leur appartient
moi ma conviction c'est que ce groupe
votera précisément parce que c'est ça
fait partie de l'ADN de ce que vous
portez depuis plusieurs années vous vous
retrouvez en position d'arbitre avec vos
62 députés comment vous vivez
être au centre du jeu politique même si
vous n'avez pas le plus grand groupe
dans l'opposition loin de là qu'est-ce
que vous allez faire maintenant la
question c'est nous on se positionne pas
pour un texte ou contre un texte en
fonction des courbettes de Madame borne
c'est pas ce qui nous intéresse nous ce
qui nous importe c'est de savoir si un
projet qui est présenté correspond à une
situation dans le pays et aujourd'hui
forcer de constater qu'effectivement
beaucoup d'entreprises je suis d'accord
avec ma collègue il manque d'emploi sur
certains postes mais il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui ont du mal à recruter
et il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
question d'assurance chômage doit être
abordée donc sur un texte comme celui-ci
on part quand même d'un vote qui aura
lieu à la fin des débats on va pas on va
pas anticiper les débats en cours
absolument ils ont mercredi la fin du
débat parlementaire après demain à
demain
part je voterai ce texte là mais sans
doute une grande partie de mes collègues
aussi nous verrons l'issue mais en tous
les cas moi j'attends pas de savoir ce
que pense madame borne de ma position de
vote c'est pas mon sujet ça ne
m'intéresse pas alors ça devrait passer
sur l'assurance
pourquoi vous me renvoyez aux Courbet de
Madame borne en fait
alors que rien n'y oblige pourquoi
voulez-vous nous voler nos plus belles
années de retraite le porte-parole du
gouvernement nous a prévenu repousser
l'âge de départ à 65 ans se fera quel
que soit la méthode qu'importe la
démocratie pour vous que vous ayez
l'ivresse de détruire nos droits pour
maintenir le marché libre et les hyper
riches bien au chaud la position qui est
la vôtre votre appel au statu quo votre
conservatisme en réalité votre position
c'est la position qui fera baisser les
retraites vous êtes le camp de
l'appauvrissement des retraités et le
temps qui veut priver nos enfants donne
droit à la retraite Thomas ménager on a
entendu Marine Le Pen s'opposer très
fermement à toute forme de reportages
légal même allongement de la durée de
cotisation la France insoumise Jean-Luc
Mélenchon défilera le 16 octobre dans la
rue vous vous irez vous pensez que c'est
aussi le terrain de la contestation non
pas du tout nous on est élu moi j'ai été
lu notamment pour m'opposer à cette
réforme donc c'est ce que je vais
m'affairer
à l'Assemblée nationale dans les
prochaines semaines mais la rue c'est
pas du tout le rôle du parlementaire
voilà aujourd'hui on va se battre parce
que ce n'est c'est totalement injuste
tout d'abord et c'est totalement
injustifié et déjà il y a aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de Françaises et de
Français qui n'arrivent pas à atteindre
l'âge de la retraite un Français sur
deux n'atteint pas l'âge de la retraite
donc ça serait totalement déraisonnable
d'envisager une réforme et c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
disait que c'était totalement hypocrite
donc il y a un certain nombre de données
qui le prouve il y a le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui l'a
indiqué et je trouve ça un petit peu
triste qu'on préfère taper sur les
retraités sur des gens qu'on travaille
toute leur vie plutôt que de trouver des
économies où il pourrait y en avoir
ailleurs à obtenir et donc c'est ça le
vrai sujet c'est d'essayer de trouver de
l'argent là où il y en a c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu un long suspense pour
savoir la méthode du gouvernement sans
doute François Bayrou a-t-il pesé
finalement elles amont d'un Gava dans le
choix de laisser un peu de temps à la
concertation des des partenaires sociaux
vous êtes avec un député MoDem allié
s'il en est de la majorité relative
alliée fidèle ou pas
alors alliés fidèle puisqu'il regarde la
séance ils ne veulent absolument pas
louper un vote qui va avoir lieu dans
quelques secondes dans l'hémicycle
est-ce que vous serez un aller loyal sur
les retraites maintenant que vous avez
gagné sur la méthode puisque Emmanuel
Macron a annoncé une concertation ce
qu'on voulait c'est la concertation
pourquoi on voulait la concertation
parce qu'il faut continuer à expliquer
aux Français pourquoi il faut faire
cette réforme et il faut aussi que tout
le monde tous les français mais aussi
tous les parlementaires et vraiment les
éléments financiers de cette réforme
comment on l'équilibre pourquoi on doit
l'équilibrer et où on va dans cette
réforme est-ce qu'on voulait nous aussi
c'est qu'on ne n'oublie pas un certain
nombre de sujets autour du travail on
parle beaucoup de la réforme des
retraites on parle en ce moment du texte
sur l'indemnisation du chômage mais je
crois que dans notre pays il faut qu'on
ait une réflexion sur le travail et donc
ça nous paraissait important qu'on est
ce cette concertation plutôt que cet
amendement
aussi la concertation n'avance pas là
vous accepterez que le gouvernement
reprenne la main passe par un 49-3 par
exemple si on voit que la concertation
n'avance pas parce qu'il y a de la
mauvaise foi on pourra se poser la
question mais visiblement moi j'espère
que les parlementaires d'un côté et les
partenaires sociaux de l'autre vont
pouvoir justement faire des pas les uns
vers les autres et le gouvernement
évidemment
on n'arrivera pas à faire cette réforme
des retraites sans qui est une
compréhension de ces enjeux par les
Français et donc on ne peut pas faire
cette réforme des retraites contre les
Français avec un amendement en 49-3
c'était le sens de notre on va dire
mise en garde pourra coûte pression
certains mais c'était plutôt une
pression justement amicale parce que
nous on est convaincu qu'il faut faire
cette réforme des retraites mais il faut
la faire de façon concertée et de façon
comment dire aussi en tenant compte les
sujets de justice sociale qui nous
tiennent à cœur au modem merci beaucoup
Erwan balade on a noté des petits coups
de pression amicaux parfois entre
partenaires de la majorité merci
beaucoup Merci à VOUS Elsa mode Braison
elle est franchement bien en manger
c'est très fort vous pensez la question
n'est pas de savoir si elle est bien
dans mon chez la question est de savoir
si elle est nécessaire et d'abord eu des
élections présidentielles ça vous aura
pas échappé le président de la
République a été élu en mettant carte en
mettant sur la table c'est très fort
mais sa volonté de la faire et ce
qu'elle devait comprendre maintenant il
me semble effectivement sain de passer
par une une phase de concertation avec
les partenaires sociaux avec les
différentes forces politiques dont un
certain nombre j'espère seront d'accord
avec nous vous députés vous étiez aussi
réservé voir au style au passage en
force j'ai un amendement dans le but de
la sécurité sociale ce qui m'importe sur
cette loi comme sur l'ensemble des lois
c'est qu'on arrive à garder une forme de
de sérénité nationale de consensus aussi
large que possible donc maintenant
et pour ça il faut il faut expliquer
pourquoi encore une fois pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait les choses pourquoi est-ce
qu'on modifie ce système de retraite on
le fait précisément parce on veut que
cette chaîne entre génération cette
chaîne de solidarité elle puisse
perdurer et puis parce que de façon plus
globale ça s'intègre dans notre projet
dans notre projet keno par rapport au
travail il faut augmenter un petit peu
le volume global de travail pour pouvoir
investir parce que un pays qui investit
moins j'entends certains qui voudraient
réduire le temps de travail c'est un
pays qui produit moins de richesse et
donc c'est un pays qui derrière
développe moins les questions
d'éducation de santé de sécurité je
comprends que les Français puissent se
poser des questions quand ils entendent
parler de cette réforme mais pourquoi on
le fait on le fait parce que c'est bon
pour nos enfants et parce que c'est bon
pour le pays Clémence gaîté vous êtes
satisfaite que le gouvernement lâche un
peu de la sur le calendrier déjà ah non
non enfin je suis pas satisfaite sur
cette question de la réforme des
retraites déjà vous m'avez pas laissé
l'opportunité mais sur assurance chômage
et dire que que cette réforme qui est
menée en ce moment est absolument
odieuse elle va plonger des gens dans
une situation de précarité aggravée
c'était déjà le cas dans le premier
volet qu'on a connu dans le mandat
précédent ça va le pire cette fois-ci et
là on est dans une phase de destruction
de notre modèle de protection sociale
qui est avancé et c'est pour ça que je
fais le lien avec le sujet de la réforme
des retraites tout ça madame Brejon le
disait c'est leur projet en effet ça se
tient parfaitement c'est un projet de
destruction de ce qui constitue le
projet pour notre
protections
mais vous non plus
vous pariez sur sur une explosion
sociale sur ce dossier là je sais que
vous allez appeler à manifester dans la
rue on a l'impression quand même que les
Français regardent un peu ailleurs sont
très très je pense que les Français sont
préoccupants
ils sont dans la difficulté sociale
voilà ils ont du mal à payer ce qu'ils
doivent payer parce que l'inflation
parce que l'énergie vous en avez parlé
parce que les salaires ne suivent pas et
que donc ils sont concentrés en effet
là-dessus notre rôle nous de
parlementaire c'est nous nous opposer à
se contre-projet de réforme des
retraites parce que c'est faux ça n'est
pas nécessaire ça c'est un élément de
langage de la macronie mais non ça n'est
pas nécessaire on pourrait très bien
faire la retraite à 60 ans la financer
notre modèle marche fonctionne il est un
des modèles les plus vertueux qui permet
aux gens justement de partir à un âge
raisonnable donc on s'y opposera dans
l'hémicycle par tous les moyens qu'il
faudra employer et puis aussi dans la
rue parce que la mobilisation sociale la
dernière fois en 2018-2019 c'est aussi
ça qui a payé et qui a fait que Macron
n'a pas pu aller au bout de cette
réforme dont les Français ne veulent pas
alors j'ai 70%
les républicains sont importants parce
qu'une fois de plus ils sont en
situation d'arbitre ou de position
charnière on stage chemine plutôt vers
un projet de loi global bonne nouvelle
ça veut dire pas forcément de 49-3 même
si le gouvernement peut avoir une carte
en dehors des textes budgétaires vous
voterez ce texte mais déjà on va déjà
voir ce qu'il y a dans le texte mais je
note je fais je fais de remarques sur la
forme je note que le Président de la
République est prêt à faire et à raison
12 mois de consultation de débats sur un
sujet aussi important que la fin de vie
et le suicide assisté et que sur un
sujet comme la réforme des retraites ça
va être bâclée en trois mois en réalité
alors que c'est un sujet extrêmement
important
les concertations et puis on peut aussi
se reposer la question sur le l'objectif
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est de préserver
une retraite par répartition et une
retraite digne pour l'ensemble des
Français ça nous sommes d'accord si on
veut préserver le modèle de retraite
répartition il faut travailler plus
attention on se rejoint on est d'accord
maintenant c'est quel est le sujet
est-ce que la variable c'est l'âge de
départ ou au contraire ce que nous
pensons de plus en plus avec certains
collègues la question du nombre
d'annuités est-ce qu'il n'est plus du
tout la même chose parce qu'une personne
qui a commencé à 18 ans et qui aurait
ses 43 années
ou c'est 44 années en fonction de
l'allongement progressif du nombre de
trimestres pourraient très bien partir
en retraite surtout que généralement
quand on débute à 18 ans on est plutôt
sur des métiers ou physiquement on est
abîmé à la fin avec tout ce que vous
avez défendu pendant la présidence
en tout cas votre partie a fait campagne
pour une retraite à 65 ans
nous expliquer comment on fait est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on augmente est-ce qu'on
augmente les impôts ou est-ce qu'on
baise la question
non non 60 ou 62 ans 60 pour ceux qui
ont commencé avant 20 ans 62 pour ceux
qui ont commencé après 20 ans avec 42
annuités donc ça c'est une réforme il y
a eu une évolution sur le sujet parce
que bah il y a eu des évolutions
l'espérance de vie aussi a évoluer après
nous aujourd'hui quand on vous écoute
quand on écoute même borne et vous
l'avez dit c'est pas uniquement pour
financer le système de retraite c'est
pour financer d'autres politiques
il nous reste une toute petite poignée
de minutes on a balayé quelques grandes
réformes
gaîté et et la droite et vous conclurez
sur le texte énergienne-nouvelable il
est très important le gouvernement
investit massivement sur l'éolien
notamment offshop et veut accélérer au
fond les procédures pour permettre de
rattraper le retard sur le renouvelable
on est très en retard nous en France par
rapport aux Allemands par exemple là
pourquoi vous êtes pas d'accord alors
bon déjà il va falloir voir comment ce
texte va nous arriver puisqu'il passe
d'abord au Sénat donc il va être
largement remanié par la droite
senatoriale il va falloir voir donc ce
que ça donne mais on n'est pas d'accord
sur plusieurs choses d'abord sur les les
ce qui n'est pas dit dans ce texte c'est
à dire que on pense que quand on doit
réfléchir à notre modèle énergétique il
faut parler impérativement de mesure de
sobriété avant tout il ne faut pas
prendre le la relance du nucléaire comme
une évidence puisqu'ensuite il y aura un
projet de loi sur la relance sobriété
pour les entreprises voilà qui est
présenté jeudi problème sous-jacent qui
ne sont pas vraiment le texte mais qui
concerne le mix énergétique et puis
ensuite sur les énergies renouvelables
on n'est pas d'accord avec la façon dont
c'est pris c'est à dire que on nous dit
ça prend trop de temps de développer un
projet d'énergie renouvelable
aujourd'hui parce que on consulte trop
les gens et parce que le droit de
l'environnement est trop contraignant la
vérité c'est que si ça prend beaucoup de
temps et ça c'est vrai en France ça
prend beaucoup de temps c'est surtout
parce que l'État et ses opérateurs n'ont
pas les moyens d'instruire les projets
assez rapidement donc nous on
revendiquer le 100% énergies
renouvelable donc évidemment on est
favorable au développement mais pas dans
ces conditions alors c'est intéressant
parce que ça clivago mais ça va clever
aussi sur l'éolien à droite vous aurez
le mot de la fin c'est miner quand même
ce terrain de la rentrée non pour
absolument sur le projet
terrestre dedans il y a essentiellement
du solaire donc on va trouver davantage
de fonciers pour arriver à implanter des
panneaux solaires notamment sur des
parkings notamment sur des DST
autoroutiers donc ça permet d'augmenter
cette surface là et c'est extrêmement
important il y a toute une question qui
dit au partage de la valeur aujourd'hui
on a un sujet d'acceptabilité je lui en
dire pour en parler notamment sur les
éoliennes terrestres dans l'Aisne on a
beaucoup probablement beaucoup trop et
donc il y a toute une réflexion sur
comment est-ce que on accompagne les
populations en ayant par exemple une
réduction immédiate sur votre facture
d'électricité
encore une fois il faut pas poser les
énergies des carbonées entre elles le
nucléaire et les énergies renouvelables
ça va de pair et notre seul ennemi c'est
le charbon et c'est les énergies
fossiles c'est dit merci merci d'avoir
participé à ce tour d'horizon à 7 jours
de rentrée parlementaire sur les grandes
réformes à venir j'ai envie de vous dire
bon courage à tous et merci à vous la
vie parlementaire c'est aussi de la
diplomatie on va accueillir à présent
notre grand témoin et le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères ici
au Palais Bourbon il revient du crâne il
faisait partie de la délégation des
députés qui se sont rendus à Kiev la
semaine dernière emmenée par Gaëlle
Braun Pivet la présidente de l'Assemblée
alors à l'heure où la situation
militaire évolue extrêmement vite ou
l'armée russe recule face à la
contre-offensive ukrainienne plein de
questions à poser à Jean-Louis bourlange
qui nous rejoint juste après
l'invitation signée Clément Méric avec
Katia
de toutes nos forces c'est par tous les
moyens à notre disposition les
États-Unis sont les seuls dans
l'histoire du monde à avoir utilisé deux
fois l'harmonie nucléaire anéantissant
les villes d'Hiroshima et Nagasaki cela
a créé un précédent
face à cette fuite en avant de Vladimir
Poutine volodi mirzenski rejette toute
forme de négociations vous avez pu le
constater vous-même en vous rendant en
Ukraine la semaine dernière aux côtés de
la présidente de l'Assemblée Yaël brune
Pivet et message que nous avons reçu
étaient des messages
ultra déterminés
je ne négocierai pas avec Poutine dans
ce contexte difficile de voir la lumière
au bout du tunnel et pourtant pour vous
derrière la violente diatribe de
Vladimir Poutine vendredi il y a
peut-être l'esquisse d'une solution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de trouver une une voix pour se sortir
lui-même de l'impasse dans laquelle il
s'est mis ça peut être quoi cette voix
c'est de dire voilà on arrête les frais
on garde les quatre provinces on garde
la Crimée et vous encaissez ça et si
vous n'en connaissez pas ça vous aurez
froid mais cette option Jean-Louis
bourlange est-elle vraiment souhaitable
après l'annexion de la Crimée en 2014
les démocraties occidentales
s'inclineraient une fois de plus face au
coup de force de Vladimir Poutine au
risque d'encourager à nouveau le recours
à la violence
bonsoir Jean-Louis bourlange bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau merci Vincent
Huchet d'être à mes côtés pour ce grand
entretien vous êtes grand reporter vous
suivez très attentivement ce conflit et
chroniqueur régulier dans cette émission
alors avant de répondre à la question
formulée par Clément Méric dans le sujet
j'aimerais vous entendre sur les
Ukrainiens que vous avez rencontré vous
avez rencontré beaucoup de responsables
politiques le président du Parlement le
gouverneur de la province de Kiev
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus marqué chez
ce peuple ukrainien qui se bat pour son
pays pour sa souveraineté il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont qui sont
marquantes et qui tranchent par rapport
à ce qu'on observe dans d'autres pays
dont l'autre c'est d'abord l'extrême
détermination
que à tous les niveaux le président du
Parlement le président
zen ski le Premier ministre nous avons
des gens qui sont
décidés à défendre à juste titre la
souveraineté de leur état dans son
intégralité et son prêt à faire les
nécessaire cette détermination elle
s'accompagne de qualité
morale impressionnante
de capacité de dévouement de
mobilisation de sacrifices l'armée
ukrainienne notamment on a pas mal de
témoignages fonctionnent une façon
extraordinairement décentralisée ce sont
des unités locales qui rassemblent les
moyens
presque empiriquement avec ce qui trouve
on reproche à un soldat des tenues sans
son couteau ils achètent leurs armes
il faut il reconstitue leur matériel en
[Musique]
déboulonnant en démontant les matériels
russes soviétiques il y a une espèce de
de
dynamisme à la base qui est
extraordinaire c'est ça qui est ce qui
est très impressionnant c'est que c'est
un machin qui une mobilisation qui vient
d'en bas on dit maintenant bottomop
j'aime pas beaucoup ce mot ça vient de
toute la société
son courage mais vous l'avez rencontré
d'abord quelle impression vous a-t-il
fait et que vous a-t-il dit d'abord il
m'a fait une très forte impression
personnelle on a toujours une impression
en le regardant la télévision mais le
voir personnellement c'est différent
c'est un homme qui vous regarde qui vous
envisage qui vous sourit qui cherche le
contact
intellectuelle presque affectif
il a énormément de charme il a un regard
très très intelligent mobile était très
très malin je dirais et en même temps il
y a derrière tout cela une inflexibilité
qui est qui a été la clé de leur succès
enfin le mot clé de toute cette affaire
c'est je n'ai pas besoin de taxi
parce que vous savez tous les militaires
vous vous disent enfin les nôtres
notamment quand on discute avec eux que
c'était à deux doigts que les rues sont
été à deux doigts de réussir leur
opération sur sur l'Ukraine que c'est
d'ailleurs la résistance de de gens à la
base là où ils ont atterri il y avait
pas beaucoup d'armées c'est la ville
entière qui s'est mobilisée le maire a
perdu la vie dans cette résistance de
quelques heures et ça a permis de
d'organiser de monter de faire monter en
puissance une ville et et à ce moment-là
tout a changé parce que l'armée s'est
mise en place et puis on a vu que ce
pays on considérait avec un petit peu de
condescendance même beaucoup de
condescendance dans le passé avait des
ressources extraordinaires on va
justement avec
des choses évoluent de jour en jour et
même d'heures en heures mais peut-être
une question sur les mots des élanski à
notre égard nous Français la France est
que de la gratitude parce que on les a
entendus les Ukrainiens quand même
reprocher à Emmanuel Macron c'est long
coup de fil à Poutine oui il y a eu un
décalage je pense que la phrase du
président de la République sur une faux
pas humilier poutine au moment où elle a
été prononcée n'était pas très heureuse
et ça a été ressenti mais je pense que
tout ceci était passé était passé
d'abord par la qualité de l'aide que
nous apportons on discute beaucoup de la
quantité de cette aide en réalité les
ukanias ne sont très reconnaissants de
donner une aide précise efficace
ponctuelle correspondant à ce qu'ils
demandent et de très grande qualité
deuxièmement il y a il y a eu le
mouvement et c'est Manuel Macron qui a
été à l'origine de ça visant à
reconnaître la légitimité de leur
candidature à l'Union européenne les
Allemands étaient très hésitants c'était
hésitant ça s'est fait dans la dans le
train si je puis dire qu'il menait à
Kiev et et là en présidence française et
je pense que le président Zelinski là a
compris que il avait vraiment
avec Emmanuel Macron un interlocuteur
amical déterminé à l'aider en tout cas
il nous a dit que des choses très
positives sur Emmanuel comme il disait
il l'appelle par son prénom et il y
avait vraiment pas l'ombre d'un doute
apparent peut-être que alors on va
regarder les cartes Vladimir Poutine on
en a parlé ici même à officiellement
reconnu en grande pompe à Moscou
l'annexion des quatre régions
ukrainiennes vendredi Louhans de NES que
ça porrigia Carson mais sur le terrain
Vincent on le voit sur la carte qui va
s'afficher l'armée russe recule dans ses
territoires
il faut regarder attentivement deux
front très différents l'un de l'autre
commençons à l'Est on vont apparaître
sur cette carte donc lougans ce que
Lucie chanz goupillantes qui est isium
ce qui est très important c'est de
considérer que bizarrement ça peut
sembler paradoxal
les positions russes sont bousculées je
dirais en lisière de l'Empire c'est à
dire qu'on est très près de la frontière
russe c'était déjà un phénomène patent
lorsque carquish était tombé deuxième
remarque qui je dois le dire plonge les
meilleures experts militaires dans un
abîme de perplexité c'est que dans cet
endroit précisément les Russes ont
essayé d'installer ce qu'on appelle en
termes militaire une ligne durcie à
hauteur d'un fleuve une rivière qui
s'appelle huskyll et il n'y arrive même
pas or se trouve là-bas les unités
réputées les plus performantes de
l'armée russe il y a par exemple une
fameuse
144e division de l'artillerie motorisé
qui a été enfoncé et les forces
ukrainiennes à bas bruit parce qu'il y a
une sorte d'opacité organisée sur leur
opérationnelle et bien on semble-t-il
franchi cette rivière hostile qui était
supposée être
la ligne de défense infranchissable et
au sud alors au sud donc là il faut
descendre un peu vers zapporizia Kerson
alors on est beaucoup plus loin
évidemment
de territoire russe il n'en n'aborde pas
moins que personne est la seule capitale
régionale qui a été conquise au tout
début de l'agression militaire que c'est
aussi un foyer de résistance extrêmement
intense c'est là que vous avez eu des
réflexes je dirais quasiment maquisard
qui nous ont un peu rappelé la France
des années 42 43 avec des initiatives
locales avec une plasticité que
soulignée Jean-Louis pour l'ange à
l'instant une capacité d'adaptation tout
à fait étonnante et une circulation de
l'information extrêmement précieuse
entre les civils et les volontaires et
les militaires là on a cru un moment que
les Russes avaient réussi en acheminant
des forces elle aussi réputé de qualité
aller réussir à geler le front or les
dernières informations celles que j'ai
pu réunir voilà quelques heures montre
qu'il y a aussi une progression
significative et là encore vous savez ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon militaire
une barrière humide en l'occurrence un
fleuve il s'agit du Nièvre le ni pro et
bien là aussi il y a eu des gains
territoriaux incontestables qui ont été
confirmés je termine là-dessus par
l'Institut pour l'étude de la guerre
américaine dont les données et les
cartes sont réputées fiables
après les commentaires de Vincent et
jeux sur cette contre-offensive
puissante de l'armée ukrainienne on
commence à se demander si les Ukrainiens
ne vont pas regagner ces quatre
provinces là et ça c'est je serais bien
incapable de vous fournir une réponse
documentée étayée fiable sur cette
question à cette question ce qui est
certain c'est que pour compléter ce que
vous avez dit il va aller tout à fait
dans le sens c'est que les les
ukraignantes étaient très rusés ils ont
fait semblant de faire porter d'abord
leur effort au sud et il y a eu une
certaine démobilisation même s'il y
avait des unités à guéries il y a une
certaine démobilisation et ils sont
intervenus au nord de façon assez
soudaine assez brusque et prenant
complètement à par surprise les Russes
c'est peut-être une des explications de
de l'anomalie que vous que vous signalez
et deuxièmement ils avaient en revanche
vraiment pas du tout avancé au sud côté
de Kerson et ça marchait pas bien le
offensive et on quand j'y étais il y a
quand même pas longtemps il y a trois
quatre jours
on disait ben au nord ça va au sud ça va
moins bien et là ce qui se passe et qui
sont quand même fait tomber
la ville de limon qui est qui était
considérément qui est considéré comme
oui un instrument qui pèse complètement
sur le dispositif russe au sud donc là
ils amorent une manœuvre de
contournement qui était effectivement
très redoutable et qui tient
effectivement en fait qu'ils ont ils ont
ils occupent des hommes qui sont très
proches de la frontière on a envie de se
dire est-ce que la seule paix possible
le retour de la paix c'est la victoire
tout simplement des secrets je crois
effectivement que ça serait ça serait
légitime et nécessaire je pense qu'on en
est pas là pour l'instant les conquêtes
sont quand même limitées
ce sont des succès très importants très
significatifs qui renverse l'évolution
des trois derniers mois parce que les
trois derniers mois les Russes
progressaient lentement bêtement
d'ailleurs à la manière de ce qu'on
faisait pendant la guerre de 14
l'artillerie détruit l'infanterie occupe
c'était c'est lamentable les Russes
progressaient dans les cimetières qu'ils
avaient créés en réalité et là ils ont
inversé le mouvement ils ont reconquis
du territoire ils l'ont reconquis au
nord et maintenant il marque de succès
au sud mais il faut pas mais ils ont eu
beaucoup de pertes ils ont eu ils ont eu
beaucoup vous savez klausvi dit que
c'est que l'offensive c'est toujours
plus dur que la défensive et l'offensive
on perd des hommes ils ont perdu les
sacrifices que font les troupes
ukrainiennes ne doivent pas être
sous-estimés ils se font avec un
héroïsme absolument vous entendez dire
dans le sujet tout à l'heure au fond que
le discours de Poutine c'était au fond
un plan de négociation je garde les
quatre régions avec la Crimée et on
négocie quand on voit ce qui se passe au
sein de la société russe depuis la
mobilisation partielle ces mères qui
refusent que leur fils a eu au combat
les enregistrements du désarroi des
soldats sur le terrain qui sont lancés
comme de la chair à canon quand on voit
aussi des divisions au sommet de l'État
avec des critiques des officiers russes
le ministère de la Défense le ministre
chahut kadirof le chef d'état-major qui
sont critiqués on se dit peut-être que
des Racim of pardon cette société va
finir par se fissurer oui mais
effectivement je ne pense pas du tout
que ce soit premier pas voilà
négociation j'ai dit simplement que je
ne ressentais pas dans un discours un
pas supplémentaire dans l'escalade il y
a pas d'allusion à l'arme nucléaire il y
a en revanche un cri de haine absolue
envers l'Occident mais ça n'est pas
nouveau en revanche je crois pour la
raison que vous venez d'indiquer
c'est-à-dire que il y a c'est une
opération de politique intérieure il
s'agit d'expliquer aux Russes que leur
gosse leurs hommes ne sont pas morts en
vain que la Grande Russie éternelle
s'est étendu à quatre blastes etc et de
valoriser cette prise dérisoire et en
cela ça peut être demain dans l'esprit
de Poutine ça pourrait être demain dans
l'esprit de pout mais ça ne marchera pas
du tout parce que les Ukrainiens
n'entendent pas céder sur ce point et
ils ont raison ils veulent récupérer la
souveraineté de leur état ce serait une
démarche qui consistera à dire écoutez
si vous voulez qu'on arrête nous on
prend les quatre régions donc on a
obtenu quelque chose on garde des
villages et espérer diviser l'Europe
occidentale sont ces bases et je crois
que nous avons nous Français qui sommes
potentiellement les cibles d'une telle
démarche de la part de Poutine nous
avons dit non nous avons dit que nous
resterions totalement fidèle à
au combat des Ukrainiens etc et à eux
seuls de déterminer les conditions de la
paix Vincent brièvement je voudrais
qu'on aborde la question
offrir à Poutine par la négociation ce
qu'il a été incapable d'arracher par
l'agression militaire serait une impasse
politique et un naufrage moral bien sûr
je voudrais qu'on termine cet entretien
un risque politique parce que pout
relancerait tôt ou tard l'action très
brièvement Vincent c'est quand même
paradoxal c'est au moment où Poutine
recule sur le terrain dans certaines
zones d'une Dombas on l'a vu sur la
carte qu'on brandit le drapeau russe en
Afrique à Ouagadougou au Burkina après
le coup d'État militaire alors c'est un
triple paradoxe pour reprendre ce
concept c'est effectivement au moment où
l'armée de la Sainte Russie
collectionne les revers les plus
cinglants sur le front ukrainien que on
l’implore de voler au secours de pouvoir
pucciste au passage n'oublions pas que
Poutine mène en Ukraine un projet
colonial de nature impérialiste ce qui
est quand même devrait un peu éveiller
les consciences des anti colonialistes
d'Afrique deuxième paradoxe c'est au
moment où l'emprise française sur son ex
précarité et la plus faible depuis les
indépendants depuis les années 60 que
l'hostilité est la plus virulente et ce
paradoxe s'explique et j'en ai pour 10
secondes par nous n'avons pas réussi à
solder nos arrières et coloniaux ce qui
a permis à la rhétorique sur la France
Afrique de prospérer et deuxièmement il
y a une intense perplexité que j'ai pu
mesurer au fil de mes reportages dans
ces pays sahéliens comment se fait-il
que la sixième armée du monde soit un
capable d'annéeantir des bandes de
djihadistes vous aurez mot de la fin
très brièvement le temps nous a manqué
et tout à fait juste simplement
il y a cet arrière-plan coloniale qui
est tout à fait tout à fait fondamentale
mais il faut il faut voir aussi que
c'est une impasse regardez le Mali
actuellement le Wagner permet à aux
autorités puchistes maliennes de
contrôler la région de Bamako est un peu
plus et ça libère complètement
l'islamisme que Poutine prétend par
ailleurs combattre et qui se répand
directement vers le Golf de Guinée avec
des des risques importants pour le Bénin
pour la Côte d'Ivoire pour la Guinée etc
c'est un échec total aussi merci
infiniment Jean-Louis Bourlon je vous
êtes invité sur ce plateau quand vous
voulez parce que on a besoin de de votre
analyse et de votre expertise sur sur la
situation en Ukraine et dans le monde
allez avant de se quitter un visage
celui d'Alain Aspect couronné du prix
Nobel de physique 2022 pour ses travaux
sur l'intrication quantique professeur à
Paris Saclay à l'École polytechnique
cocorico prix Nobel qui partage il le
partage avec d'autres collègues
américains et autrichiens très belle
soirée à demain
[Musique]